wir haben hunderttausend abonnenten auf
dem kanal geknackt ihr seid der hammer
ich weiß überhaupt nicht was ich sagen
soll außer danke danke danke müssen
irgendwas unternehmen um das gebührend
zu feiern finde ich und draußen ist es
super kalt guck mal das ist der letzte
tag an dem es noch so richtig viel
schnee gibt draußen da werden wir jetzt
einfach mal eisbahn geben
dicke decke aus meinem team die kommt
gleich vorbei und wir waren eben in der
teambesprechung hat kilian der ist unser
grafikdesigner zufällig mitbekommen was
wir vorhaben und gesagt ich war gestern
alles fahren indem sie hier in der nähe
und deswegen kommt kilian jetzt auch mit
und zeigt uns nur das ist und wie das
funktioniert weil ich habe das auf jeden
fall noch nie gemacht und ich bin total
aufgeregt und dann springen wie bei
minus 20 grad in rehe ein quatsch nicht
mehr draußen das ist jetzt letzte tag an
dem sie überhaupt - gerade hat und
morgen so eure frauen über 15 garten
[Musik]
die uhr so ausfindig schief gehen oder
die durchblutung stabilisiert den
kreislauf glückshormone
ich hab da hat man kann teilweise gar
nicht man hat mich niemals alleine also
die brust getreten und generell sehr
sehr vorsichtig sein man kann da einen
schock bekommen so dass man nicht mehr
tun kann untergehen kann wir haben uns
extra sicherheiten mitgebracht um das im
zweifel hoffentlich zu verhindern
aber im großen und ganzen härte sich so
an als ob das ein sehr simples
fördernder industrie spur
[Musik]
ich weiß dass ich mich nicht mehr
bewegen kann weil es so kalt ist oder
irgendwie so und dann eben als
badestellen sehr beliebt geworden und es
gibt vereine die gemeinsam ausbaden
und die haben richtig krachen das kannst
du machen dass in der calle de s
wir müssen das doch etwas zeigen deren
[ __ ] dabei begann dann keine hacke der
gerther ein bisschen feuchtigkeit aus
das ist ja wohl das reicht noch nicht
können okay gut
er wollte nicht noch mal ein break aber
es hat schon noch ein genannt
ich kann das auch machen und handschuhe
anziehen
[Musik]
kann man das jetzt damit unser verbrauch
die zahl und an den prüfungen
[Musik]
auf dem prozess haben die beiden
reingehangen so dass wir uns hinten
reinrutschen
[Musik]
hier nutzte das seil
wenn du für deine haut ist auch
controller also eigentlich schade das
ist jetzt schon wieder vorbei naja wir
das hier gemacht hätten dann wäre ich
noch mal hergekommen gar nicht auf dem
schirm das ist eine coole sache machen
[Musik]